jamais le canada n'a connu une crise
aussi importante en temps de paix selon
la banque nationale la crise actuelle va
faire chuter le pib de 18% par rapport à
son sommet la grippe espagnole avait
entraîné une baisse de 6 8% du pib
les récessions classique de 1981 90-91
2008-2009 d'hercule entre trois et demi
et cinq et demi pour ça on a parlé avec
stéphane marion qui est économiste et
stratège en chef à la banque nationale
bonsoir stéfane marion bonsoir monsieur
fignon l'impact de la pandémie sur le
pib du canada dépasse tout ce qu'on a
connu dans le fort jusqu'à maintenant
oui j'aimerais peut-être apporter une
nuance importante la base du 18 pour
cent qui avait mentionné ce sera entre
le mois de février est le mois d'avril
avec le déconfinement qui est maintenant
en cours
ça devrait se terminer avec une moyenne
annuelle autour de - 7 % mais
effectivement le moins 18% ce qui était
important de ce que vous avez montré
dans le graphique sait qu'historiquement
les récessions décrété par les
gouvernements ou non de la santé
publique y avait qu un seul épisode qui
avait été observé auparavant ce que
celui la pandémie de 1918 contraction
est exceptionnel et cette fois ci comme
s'est décrétée par le gouvernement dans
un contexte où les économies sont plus
des économies de service et plus
intensive en main d'oeuvre mais le choc
est beaucoup plus brutale cette fois ci
et je pense que c'est une excellente
nouvelle de voir de déconfinement qui
s'opèrent à partir du 1 mois et demi
alors je montrais le moins 18 c'est
quand même spectaculaire on va montrer
d'autres données sur l'emploi parce
qu'il ya chute du pib ya chute de
l'emploi également avec une forte hausse
du chômage la chute de l'emploi ce que
tu dis est quand même plus importantes
au canada qu'en suède par exemple qu'est
ce qu'on observe à tu bats deux choses
des choses qui sont inédites
c'est que pour la première fois en une
récession ou le choc sur l'emploi et pru
plus brutal que sur le pib étant donné
les secteurs qui étaient très intenses
efforts main d'oeuvre et on voit que les
stratégies qui ont été différentes
à travers plusieurs pays donc en suède
par exemple au mois d'avril le taux de
chômage était à 8 % parce que c'est la
stratégie pour faire face à la pandémie
était de moins confiné l'économie que ce
que le canada le québec et les états
unis ont fait donc c'est la raison pour
laquelle les déficits gouvernementaux
sont beaucoup plus importants
canada-états-unis québec qu'ils ne le
seront en suède donc ces deux stratégies
très différentes par rapport à la
pandémie et on verra au cours des
prochaines semaines
qui avait raison oui parce que la suède
a fait un choix que la santé publique
ici à laquelle la santé public n'adhère
pas nécessairement alors il faudrait
voir effectivement qui aux raisons sur
le plan de la santé publique sur le plan
économique est ce que vous pensez que la
suède vaut mieux s'en sortir donc le
canada et les états unis mais je pense
que oui parce que les données
au début personne ne voulait prendre de
risques au nom de la santé publique mais
les données économiques qui qui sortent
présentement même de celle de la santé
publique démontre que 90% des gens qui
décident qui décèdent du coc vides sont
des gens qui sont de 70 ans et plus dont
des gens qui ne sont pas dans le milieu
du travail
or pendant la pandémie de 1918 80% des
gens qui décédées de la grippe espagnole
était des gens qui étaient soit présent
ce marché du travail où les enfants
alors que les aînés qui épargne et donc
dans le contexte actuel
le choix de la suède jusqu'à présent
n'apparaît pas comme un choix qui soit
dérisoire par rapport aux autres pays
parce qu'ils ont protéger davantage
leurs économies ils ont pris un risque
mais jusqu'à présent les données
statistiques semblent leur donner raison
est ce que ça vous fait dire dans les
circonstances qu'on devrait accélérer la
reprise du travail
moi je pense que dans un contexte où on
sait maintenant qu'ils sont les gens
vulnérables qu'on développe un protocole
pour protéger les aînés je pense qu'il
faut commencer à des copines et
continuer ad confiné pour s'assurer qui
est pas une destruction permanente de
capacité dans l'économie qui pourrait
amener d'autres problèmes sociaux
monsieur fillion donc des problèmes de
dépression consommation etc avec
marché du prêt du travail qui seraient
des primes est donc encore une fois
j'applaudis le fait que les autorités
budgétaires monétaires sont intervenus
fortement mais maintenant ça nous prend
une base de payeurs de taxes qui soit
crédible à moyen terme
on doit ramener avoir au moins 55% de la
population qui se remettent au travail à
court terme là pour s'assurer que notre
système de sécurité sociale soit
financée à moyen terme
vous dites ça prend 55 pour ça des gens
qui sont au travail et de la population
active c'est ça donc en général nos
études à la borie nationale démontre
qu'en de ca de 55 % la capacité
d'honorer le contrat social est remise
en question la base j'ai passé des gens
qui travaillent pour payer taxes pour
payer ce contrat social de piètre
qualité sociale
présentement au canada en est tombée on
est passé de 60% à 52 % donc un ratio
qui avait pas été observé depuis 1962
mais je vous rappelle qu'à cette époque
là y'avait pas d'assurance maladie c'est
pas le même philippe cury sociale donc
faut revenir à 50 50 à 55%
le plus rapidement possible donc on est
à 52 vous dites qu'il faut revenir à 55
parce qu'on va le voir dans le graphique
que vous avez pris faire réparer le
déficit du gouvernement canadien est
quand même extrêmement important quand
on regarde la perspective historique là
par rapport au pib il faut remonter à la
deuxième guerre mondiale pour voir
déficit par rapport au pib aussi
important c'est en dehors d'un conflit
mondial confirmé on n'a jamais vu un
déficit de cette ampleur mais encore une
fois comme c'est un confinement de
l'économie qui a été ordonnée par le
gouvernement
le gouvernement n'avait pas de choix que
de s'immiscer dans l'économie de façon
plus agressive mais de toute évidence ce
déficit la cette dette gouvernementale
là va devoir être financé par des
payeurs de taxes à moyen terme
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
devons reconstituer notre bassin payeurs
de taxes et ramener les gens au travail
dernier graphique on voit que les
économies commencent à revenir à la
normale
alors ce que vous avez là ici celle
indices de retour à la normale c'est le
pourcentage de
changement par rapport aux débuts du
confinement la suède les états unis le
canada l'espagne
donc ce que pouvait constater un
monsieur fillon vous c'est très
apparente la suède au moins qu'on finit
son économie que les autres pays et donc
ils ont certes un retour à normale donc
ils sont encore sont pas la normale mais
ils sont beaucoup plus proches de la
normale que d'autres pays tels le canada
les états unis et l'espagne et je pense
que dans la mesure où on connaît
maintenant de plus en plus qui sont les
gens vulnérables
il ya une capacité de converger
peut-être plus vers le modèle suédoise
de continuer ad confiné analyse très
intéressante stéfane marion merci merci